here's kyle seeger the number three
hitter
this guy goes up to the plate hunting
fastball especially early in the count
deep center field hill going back and
that ball is caught
he took it off the wall derrick hill
with a spectacular
play in center field wow
he banged into that wall hard these are
catches you just
you just are in awe with right over the
top of the wall
and his right shoulder maybe i don't
know what it is
what a reaction from mize what a play by
derek hill
he hit that wall pretty darn hard with
his right side
it was that final leap where he almost
dove into it with his shoulder
akil badu gives him a fist pump and akil
badu is going to
take over in center field first base
runner early tonight for the tigers
niko goodrum the batter
good room deep ride out to right field
dylan thomas
leaping welcome to the show
nobody talked about dylan's glove
what a catch in his big league debut
dylan thomas
go get him how about making a play like
you've been up here
all year long mike great play times his
lead perfectly crashing into the pins
he's excited about it and why wouldn't
you be
look at taylor trammell that's right
jonathan can maybe shoot the ball i
think that's his intent with a pitch
away anyway
he sends it to left that'll work frayley
catches it
rogers tags one-nothing tigers on the
sacrifice fly from jonathan scope
he hit it hard unfortunately there was a
man standing there
otherwise he might have got a double
jake rogers drives one deep right center
field that's got some carry
that ball was crushed and it's gone
wow that's a little bit of whooping
right there
take a look here jake rodgers gets the
front foot down that falls away from him
love this swing here look at the hips
and the hands work together that's
knocking that front side of loose
staying through the baseball
and hitting a bomb to right center that
is a
long long way 423
feet that is the longest home run of
jake rogers career
grossman a couple of flyouts so far here
tonight the 0-1
to right field and over the head of shed
long junior
the dew will try and score he will do so
without a throw
tigers add another one it's three
nothing you knew that badou is going to
score from second but
put three runs up on the board instead
of two now casey mize
going into the second half of this game
in the sixth inning he's got a little
breathing room there's room for error
now he can be aggressive
he was blown out a couple of times was
robbed his first time up
seeger out to right field no
doubt about this one way gone
up near the concourse kyle seeger with
one
swing has tied this game in the sixth
inning
i think he deserved that after his first
at bat you're right about that
426 feet the one that was robbed was 429
feet exit v low of 109 96 miles an hour
and turns it around
almost to the concourse that's a bomb
yeah they can also make mistakes and
this guy's hit a lot of mistakes in his
a career to left that's going to get
down
cabrera holds a lead off single
for the tigers in the ninth mighty
opens up and turns on a fastball
maybe in his younger days he would have
been standing on second but he does the
wise thing there
one out one on isaac paredes to batter
paredes clubs this to left field fraley
leaps and freely
the catch are you serious shed
gets two wow
unreal holy smokes what a double play
at three to three jake fraley way over
the wall
in left field robbing isaac paradise
with a game-winning home run and we're
going to the 10th time
thomas our phantom runner as we start
the 10th
mazara thomas motoring to third
and thomas is into third base
bazar's always had a great throwing arm
able to beat it
keep his foot on the bag here comes j.p
crawford
into left field who else but j.p
crawford
and he just continues to hit he's put
the mariners in front in the 10th inning
and no surprise going the other way
already had a base hit going the other
way a double
infield drawn in and there's another
base hit
this kid has put some excitement early
on in the season
in these big pressure situations
is that a good night at the plate now
the 1-1
that gets away from murphy here comes
paredes and we're tied again
what a crazy game you're looking for a
break
tiger's got a break right there it's a
slider that gets away from catcher tom
murphy
paradise can walk home he slides but
notice how he didn't square up and keep
the ball
in front he just basically shifts
towards it
hannah the go ahead run at third france
now at first
craley in the center badou having to
play it on a short bounce
haniger is in to score jake fraley
give that man the key to the city he has
put the mariners in front
five to four he's gotten it done with
the glove and now with the bat in the
11th inning
[Music]
and this center field hit first big
league knock dylan thomas
comes in extras and drives in some
damage for the mariners
tramell pointed his way congratulations
dylan
thomas who has now made it 7-4 mariners
in the 11th
murphy stings this fair
kicking around in left field shed long
junior scores
dylan thomas is coasted home as well
not helmets kicking around someplace who
cares
9-4 meriters in the 11th now the 2-1
drives one to deep right field that ball
is history
a two-run blast by robbie grossman
and the tigers are kicking up their
heels
in their half of the 11. again it's a
crazy game
robbie crushes that ball with the runner
on second that puts him within
three last hope for the tigers no mar
mazzara
popped up seeger and foul ground
and that is all she wrote tonight the
mariners
get the win in 11 innings tonight 9-6
over the tigers